you know those with a good day those
with a good - because everybody always
says those are the good days
everybody say now they want you to buy
their house a three-hour Karcher name
will stop you getting equipped to become
financially free that you are so
stoppable like the very very first
hurdle that there is to the journey
before you've even been trained up your
sparks by two or three hour or even six
hour car journeys when there's other
people come to the crash course from all
over the world that people come from
Australia like I don't even want people
like that at the crash course focus on
making get money focus on the running
mate
activities do not spend six months and
six thousand pounds and becoming
compliant and then spending another
three thousand pounds to a compliant
mental should you have to do it come on
get real so pretty mad about this all
right so Wednesdays and then five is
gonna be the weekend listen you want to
be financially free he's gotta get used
to working this financial freedom is
easy but it requires hard work 2019 over
a hundred people have become financially
free it's gonna happen again in 2012
don't try to figure out XYZ just walk
the ABC the answer is always on the
other side of the hill you're also gonna
be the person who thinks about it and
sees everybody else doing it well you're
gonna be the person that actually does
it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]